we are at what station are we at again
Sean London Bridge I think and we're off
to Sid Cup on a train that's going to uh
the wonderfully named Brave's end we're
going to Dave's and Dave is going to mix
remix remaster a Quantum metal song So a
metal song that has quantum physics
written into its very core in terms of
the Rifts in terms of The rhythms in
terms of the lyrics lots and lots of
subtle links to quantum physics in there
and lots of lots of not so subtle links
to quantum physics in there
[Music]
doesn't get much more exotic than this
over the last I'd love to say a year or
two it's been maybe 10 years since this
has been brewing back a long time ago
for number five not for 60 symbols uh
worked with another YouTuber to do a
song or get a metal song based around
the golden ratio and you can find it if
you look up Golden Ratio song number
five you'll find it
[Music]
that was a huge amount of fun and ever
since then I've wanted to Let's push
that a little bit further and let's
really bring it and go beyond the math
but also to bring the physics in and
it's not just about mapping the riffs to
certain constants like we did with that
number file song that's important
similarly to The rhythms but to go a
little bit beyond that and really have
the lyrics also embed so much of the
quantum physics so what I've done over
the past 10 months is record the guitars
when I get a chance record the bass the
drums are something called Aero drums
which we also did a video on
a lot of the aspects of the music of the
song what I had in mind was the
Schrodinger equation and in particular
the time dependence schroding equation
which is really the core not just the
quantum physics but so much of physics
and so much of the material world around
us so it's a question of trying to map
the music onto aspects of the schroding
equation and aspects of quantum physics
in general
key difference and possibly the most
important Central difference compared to
that number file song is this time I
wanted to get the students involved to
get our undergraduates involved thank
you for turning up
they try that's brilliant thanks a lot
and to have them contribute to the song
and actually have them sing and chant
and add their voices to the song and so
we had a wonderful time going into B1
our largest lecture theater invited the
students along they came along to sing a
number of certain aspects of the song
There's a chant in the middle they've
got them to chant along to keep on going
we've got those recordings we've got the
students in the lecture theater
now we've got all those files to Dave
and that's what we're going to spend the
next few hours days weeks mixing
remixing and mastering this particular
song Phil sent me the files last night
and I've put them all into Cubase now
I've lined them up to the grid so the
tempo fits and everything and I've just
visually organized it makes all the drum
tracks are together and they're all
colored when you're navigating around
how many tracks has this got it's got
about 60 odd tracks hasn't it really
entirely coincidental but it is quite
nice that there are 60 tracks
yeah probably be more than that by the
time um I get but it's it's
um a lot of the first pass phase is
going through and making sure that the
different instruments don't interfere
with each other so for example
something could sound like a guitar
could sound really good on its own have
loads and loads of bottom in loads and
loads of Base loads of long frequencies
in it but then you get too many of those
type of instruments all happening at the
same time
and then you just get this muddy sound
where everything's merging with
everything else so the first start is is
to think of it like like real estate so
it's it's like this instrument has got
that part of the spectrum this
instrument's got that part of the
spectrum there can be some Crossovers
and there will be but it's it's trying
to make sure that everything's clear and
then you can mix and do other things
from there because if you're starting
from a place where everything's
interfering with each other we're just
going to have a bad mix and particularly
from metal where the guitar is often set
exactly where the bass frequencies are
as well but there'll also be some other
interesting things on there because the
drums on this are electronic and and
kind of electronic in terms of the in
terms of the sound but the the we did a
video a while back on Air Jordans I love
Aerodrome there are electronic in the
sense that it's midi but not electronic
in the sense that they're not programmed
so they are real real which is why
they're so crap and Dave's going to have
to do um so much tidy enough as I do
certain things which for me are standard
audio techniques I'm gonna be like what
application would this process have if
you were dealing with data from a from a
satellite or something these are
mathematical functions as we're looking
at we've got some signal that's varying
this time we've got a mathematical
function what you're going to be doing
is furry analysis we've got just
hundreds of it and uh
[Music]
so the places I'm going to start is with
the drums because
um this might not be a physics thing but
it certainly is an audio thing in the
mixing thing if you don't have a solid
drum sound and then you know almost
anything else you can get away with but
you need your drums to to punch and
absolutely I know you gave me a
reference Black Sabbath song but I did
so I like aspects of that but I also
think if it was mixed like that in the
modern age I think it wouldn't compare
to Modern stuff it needs to be
absolutely a little bit more Punchy
there you go let's start with the bass
drum
one of the things I'd usually do is is
just find a frequency point and just
kind of move it along now can we stop it
as Sean can you get this can't express
just how much physics this is this is a
band of frequencies when we are doing
our experiments with moving single atoms
we use a Teensy tiny tuning fork to
image the atoms and to move the atoms to
pick up to pick up on the the force
between the atom at the end of the tip
and the atom at the surface and this
type of variation of amplitude with
frequency we do all the time in the lab
this is how we tune up our experiment
the links here are incredibly important
okay so I'm just gonna
bit of pink noise
the reason we call it pink noise is
because we have instead of having White
Noise where you have equal intensity in
all the frequencies with pink noise it
falls off it's the audio equivalent of
the color pink if we wanted to have pink
how would we mix up our colors how would
we mix up our frequencies if we want to
have pink in terms of sound it's a
question of how we mix up those
frequencies yeah musically speaking it's
a lot better to use pink noise than
white noise
um so I've got that there so what I've
done here I've got the pink noise
generator yeah you can see the fall off
in the in the graph so that's the
frequencies so um 60 symbols I've spent
a lot of time going on about furry
analysis what we have here is our
Fourier Transformer Fourier Spectrum
which is showing us the frequencies that
make up that signal it's just physics
everywhere at the moment what I've got
is I've got the pink noise and then I'm
sending it to another Channel and I've
put it out of phase so as this is a
physics Channel everyone's going to know
that if you put two things out of phase
they sum to zero which then means that
if I want to put an EQ across it just to
kind of demonstrate what eqs do sort of
musically speaking and also in the
physics world so if I put an EQ across
one side of that pink noise that's out
of phase we can lift up frequencies
and that even looks lorenzian to me in
terms of that shape
so we call that a cue so if I turn it
away up and down the queue I can change
yeah what we want to do in our
experiments in the lab is to get the
highest possible cue that you can have q
stands for quality and it's the quality
of the resonance and if you have
something sharp like that it means you
get an awful lot of signal at a
particular very narrow range of
frequencies if you spread it out and
have a lower cue that effect is spread
out over a much wider range of
frequencies Dave can if you yeah if I go
to like 500 Hertz and then yeah
but I mean from a musical point of view
you can make some interesting things I
mean if I was to put one on each octave
for example
almost the Doctor Who theme there yeah
we need a thumb yeah so that's what eqs
do is you're literally saying well this
particular set of frequencies I want to
boost the amplitude of those frequencies
and cut the amplitude of other
frequencies and then you want to narrow
the bell curve and say which range of
frequencies you want to include and
which ones you don't but why introduce
the pink noise why not do it on there
well no I was introducing the pink noise
to be able to give an active
demonstration where you from Silence you
can see which frequencies turn up now
one technique that we might get into
later is to use the pink noise because a
snare drum has snares underneath which
kind of make this sort of sound which
doesn't really have any specific pitch
or anything like that so one technique I
might have later on is to actually EQ a
bit of that pink noise to kind of get a
sound and it will give it this kind of
understeer sound so we're going to try
and simulate the sound of microphones
that don't exist in the 70s they're
physical tape machines recording stuff
onto you know magnetic media and they
didn't have enough tracks to have
15 mics around a drum kit or whatever so
they they would record the snail with
One mic and then use techniques like
that to try and simulate it afterwards
because
at the end of the day it's all smoke and
mirrors it's all cheating isn't it and
again that's the uncertainty principle
in action in that if you have something
I've banged on about this and so many
times before 160 symbols videos but I'm
gonna bang on about it again
unapologetically so if you have
something that is very wide in time so a
just a perfect note like a
we have a very narrow frequency spectrum
so wide in time narrow in frequency
however if we're talking about the snare
or something like that which is very
time limited that has a very wide
frequency spectrum associated with so
wide in time now around frequency narrow
in time wide in frequency ultimately
that's the guts of the the uncertainty
principle either in the when it comes to
Sound Engineering or indeed when it
comes to quantum physics
so I'm just going to sweep through
so it's got quite a nice punch to it
what I tend to do is find the sub that's
got the most rings so that's where the
most punch is and then bring it just a
little bit below
so we're not pushing exactly where the
ring is but then the problem is when you
bring in the base and you bring in
bottom heavy guitars
do you not
yeah I mean that that's why you need to
so where is the I want the bass drum to
be the lowest
I want that to represent that real
bottom end there
and then all of this horrible stuff
you're gonna pull out okay so all about
remained without the mod and then
that's just horrible yeah I thought it
really is
and then start I'm doing big broad
movements yes just to get a feel of it
and then I'll tweak it later I'm not
even worrying about cues and stuff
[Music]
so you still get a bit of it
but then you're actually boosting the
frequencies they're a little bit lower
that are missing listening to it's on
its own EQ is only going to take you so
far you need to listen in the context of
the the whole mix and I was just
listening to this that's horrible so I'm
just
[Music]
I'm just going to start with something
like that this hi-hat was I remember
listening to this so I'm not going to
bother with the full EQ on this
I'm going to create two different groups
here so I'm going to have drums all
which actually should be the the last
one in the chain and I'm going to do
drums trash what we're going to do with
the drums trash is I'm going to use a
compressor so fiercely
that it just distorts the signal and and
and
fudges it up and then you just mix a
little bit in underneath and the whole
thing just and because it's distorted
your bandwidth's really large so yes so
you just end up and sometimes a little
bit more of a stereo image on that so
that you you get and then I'm going to
show you on the final drums or a little
technique where you do
um
you use middle and side so so to get
sort of mathematical on it and then you
you tell me whether there's any
application for this I mean you you have
two signals coming in which in our case
is left and right but you know because
anything could be anything doesn't
matter it's two signals that obviously
related to each other and happening in
some sort of time sequence and what you
do is you find out what's similar you
this is sum them together
and get the similarity and then you put
the sides out of phase with each other
and you cancel that so you get only
what's different and you treat them
differently so you say this is the
stereo information this is the stuff
that's different in the two seasonal
cities and stuff that's the same and
then you can compress and EQ them
differently because quite often with a
drum kit you've got all the room and the
width and the excitement happening there
and I want that to never be lower than
that and never be higher than that and
then we've got all our Punchy bass drum
whatever there and I want that to be
different because they're they're coming
out of the software we haven't got this
problem but obviously with a real drum
kit and you mic it up you get a lot of
background noise from each a lot of
bleeding as you say
um
and then you can use things where you're
Shifting The Wave files by like samples
at a time to be able to line things up
because you might find that when you
play the snab and then you've got a mic
that's very very close to it okay you're
going to hit that snare drum and that
sound will go into that microphone and
obviously the speed of sound in whatever
atmospheric pressure you've got in that
drum room will take time before it goes
up to the mic by the time the sound has
got from the snare drum to the overheads
you might end up with the wave being the
other way up and then they cancel each
other out now in the old days you'd have
on the desk you'd have a button and it
would just be face and that's what you
could do do you do do you is it
literally plus or minus 90 or plus or
minus 180 or do you no it's just 180
it's just the 180 right not every
frequency that's going from the scenario
I mean it's a different microphone so it
will have a different frequency response
it will be picking up different
frequencies at different levels plus the
air and the mixing of the other
instruments will change the the
frequencies so you'll end up with little
patches of cancellation within your free
Spectrum to the the microphone now
sometimes that can sound nice you can
tune in and there's beautiful ways of
putting like a single mono mic in front
of a kit particularly if you've got a
really roomy sound and then you get a
couple of room mics and you can get it
really boomy and then you just flip the
phase of that front bike and end up
taking out some of that room and
sometimes during a song you could have
like a verse that's all delicate and
have it in Phase where you're hearing
all the room and everything and then it
kicks in for a really heavy chorus and
you want the kit to be tightened you'd
literally just flip the phase on One mic
and the whole drum sound changes you
know and it's there's there's so many
things you can do by deciding to
deliberately put things out of phase or
keep them in and that's that's something
that we're always dealing with with
audio we're always trying to you know
which again set is what you're doing
with yeah physics the administration of
waves yeah but ultimately all the
weirdness of quantum mechanics all the
weird wacky stuff is down to face I've
got the whole drum kit going through a
compressor that is in middle and side so
we've got the mono data on one channel
and the stereo data it's almost turned
two channels into three channels right
so at the moment I'm just listening to
what stereo nothing nothing that would
be in the middle of the mix
and um
because a lot of that is going to be top
end
if I have the attack time really if it
takes ages before the compressor
actually does anything because the
frequencies are so short nothing's going
to happen so I'm going to turn my attack
time right and the reason it's top end
is because of course the only things
that I've had left and right are the
same oh the symbols and you get a little
bit the click of the toms come through
the bottom end of the thumb tend to stay
in mono but the slap of the stick
hitting the Tom and the snap of the
their things that will be on and you
know on a kit that's recorded mic that
mics they're the things that are going
to be in Stereo and
to get a nice drum sound sometimes it's
almost like I want always there to be I
never want there to be any less than
this amount of stereo room sort of stuff
I never want it to be more than that so
it always has a certain width and then I
want the mono to again it's it's
controlling it's manipulating
controlling and raining everything in
just a little bit at a time and just
putting things on Reigns you know and
then eventually you end up with
something that hopefully sounds somewhat
beautiful I mean I don't know about this
bit of metal with beautiful probably
it's beautiful yeah yeah you get the
idea so with the stereo stuff I'm
basically turning the attack time that's
actually down because these are reversed
but I'm I'm I'm making it with a really
fast attack really fast release and
we'll see
foreign
[Music]
just to kind of keep that stereo data to
a to a certain point now if I go back to
the mono here
we want the attack time quite High
[Music]
I'm going to just call this uh snare SD
for snare drum uh pink noise
another reason I like to capitalize all
my channel names it makes them easier to
read at a distance I want to put the the
generator across it
ah go away I'm gonna put a gate across
it and a gate just for the reminder a
gate is basically something that says if
the signal is over this level we're
going to let it's the signal through if
the signal goes below this threshold
we're not going to allow it to through
what I want is I want this gate and you
can actually hear there it sounds like
it takes time to turn off so that's the
release time of the compressor
yeah yeah so what what I want to do is I
want to sidechain this so this isn't
reacting to the pink noise it's reacting
to the snare drum so I'm going to
activate the side chainsaw so I'm going
to put in the snare drum there are less
parameters on a beam Lane
[Music]
so if I now turn down a few parameters
oh my God that was bad
Steven Fry's not going to watch this I
won't worry so effectively every time at
the moment very rudimentary I haven't
really done a lot with it every time the
snare hits we're just getting a burst of
pink noise
as you see by using the release times
and the hold you can shape that as you
want so it'd be like there'll be a rise
of attack time then you can hold it for
a matter of time and then there'll be a
mount that it turns it down which is the
the release so it's just adding a life
to the whole
[Music]
and now I'll probably go to this and add
a
little bit more crack on the stair
so this um we got to the point where I'm
sort of happy things will be tweaked
when the rest of the music comes in but
I'm sort of happy with where we've got
the drum sound at the moment given the
the material on this so this is what
Phil sent through off his mix of it
and this is where we've got to
yep I'm happy with that you can hear
this now I'm already hearing there I
think once the rest of the music go on
the snare needs a little bit more crack
and probably a little bit less of that
Reverb there's things that we will have
to work on things that sound on their
own you can push up too much stereo you
can add reverbs and then in the context
of the mix so I need to start stripping
that back so tentatively it sounds nice
for now it's fantastic
I'm tidying up his drumming now he's
been very harsh on himself poor
um poor man
um but he's a physics Professor he's not
a drummer so I think considering he's
not a drummer I think he's drumming is
absolutely excellent he's better than my
drumming and I'm an actual professional
musician I mean I'm a guitarist no no
but I think you're probably the best
physics Professor drummer at Nottingham
University would you say that in yeah
yeah in your office
on a Tuesday the problem is on a serious
point is that
things can be a little bit out of time
and it's fine but but
um as we were discussing earlier high
frequencies are narrower physically
narrower so when you've got the slap
particularly in metal or something like
that when you've got a slap of a snare
and the slap of a bass drum and you've
also got the slap of the bass guitar and
whatever if they're marginally out you
wouldn't hear it on a long frequency
being large yet but on a short frequency
you're going to hear them as like and
they'll flam with each other so I'm
going through and tweaking up his timing
but what you find is the more you tweak
then the more you need to tweak and you
need to tweak and you go in there so
there's always trying to keep a balance
in the two but
you know you're drumming was is I've
I've had people that call themselves
drummers who play drums in a band
that are less in time than you so don't
you want yourself as well yeah yeah
don't beat yourself up over it you can
see the Peaks there's there's a hard
line at the beginning of where something
interesting happens and I just want to
snap it to the bar you know and this is
um beautiful algorithms I have no idea
how they work they're stretching waves
keeping the
pitchers yeah without without sounding
grainy at all which is just a master of
modern science and hats off to the
people who write those kind of
algorithms because I haven't got a clue
and as a producer you do this pretty
much for any yeah would to some degree I
mean if it was kind of like real loose
jazz or something you would be doing
less of it it would only be maybe the
beginning of a bar if the base was meant
to land with the drums and it was so
wildly out it was bad but it's just
minor tweaks minor tweaks and and and
we'll get there
[Music]
oh that was awful
[Laughter]
so let's move on to base I like to have
all the drums on fader and eventually
although I'm going to group all the
Acoustics all the guitars all the vocals
and have them on groups all of those
will be sent to a single group so in the
end We'll add two faders which is the
drums and everything else oh really and
you tend to I tend to find as I put more
and more instruments in I need to pull
back that everything else just to allow
the drum because you put stuff on top of
the drums and then they get hidden and
usually at the end I just find at first
it's like a DB down and usually by the
end I'm like three or four DB down to
allow the drums still through and it's
just a
it's a constant narrow you've got all
these instruments and then we group
those together to that those kind of
nodes and then they all end up and
obviously n everything ends up with the
stereo pair but the final set of nodes
before the the final stereo pair for me
always is all drums everything else
it's more difficult to do on analog
discs so it wouldn't be but
[Music]
first thing I'm going to do is um
is I'm going to put like a bass amp
simulator yeah I want it to sound like
it's been through an amp I want to
pretend it's been through a valve and
had all those Corners rounded up that's
just the raw signal straight in
effectively I see the bass guitar as as
two different instruments right there's
the bottom end
everything below let's say 80 90 Hertz
right
and then there's everything above that
three four hundred Hertz which is this
nice bit is competing with the beer
strong right yes so what we want to do
is where I was peaking the bass drum
trying to get the peak about 50 hertz
something like that to get real low I'll
be winding up the bottom and basically I
want the bass to start at about 60 and
then disappear again about 90. okay and
we're going to have that and we'll
compress that to keep it within limit so
there's always a certain amount of
bottom end and then I'll get rid of all
of that horrible stuff that we don't
want and have on a separate channel oh
another
base which is the same original signal
but is everything that's the top end so
we're treating the two things
differently so it imagine it as you had
two bass amps you had a bass guitar you
split out to do bass amps and this base
is doing all the low end and this space
amps doing all the top end and then we
can put saturation Distortion stuff over
the top end
so just going to duplicate the track so
we've got two copies that are identical
so this first one so first thing I want
to do is get rid of all that top end
[Music]
and then the bottom end get with some of
that as well
so basically below 60 hertz here and
then obviously I need to gain that up
quite a bit because I've cut most of the
energy out of it so
and then
um I'm going to use a very mild
compressor I don't want it to sound like
it's being compressed really so I'm
going to use a simulator here of an SSL
desk compressor which is known for being
transparent I know it's not a real one
it's just a software version but you
know
and we're talking about long
wavelengths so again the attack time
needs to be long enough to be actually
be able to deal with those you don't
want it to be
responding to to Transit it's not that
there's going to be any chances you see
what well this there are clicks on the
in terms of the transients in terms of
but not with this because we've cut out
oh yeah of course all the top ends we've
kind of got this
constant bottom end now so now we're
just dealing with just the upper
frequencies
I'm going to pull in the top end a bit
more because on a base you're not
looking at 10K you know and I'm going to
put this through a guitar amp simulator
so we're not going to write through a
bass amp oh we run it through a guitar
amp back in the day bass amps were
guitar amps that were just like sure
sure so when you go back to Hendrix and
stuff like that he'd have his 50 watt
Marshall heads with four inputs on stage
and the bass player would have the same
head but it would be 100 watt and he'd
have three of them you know so I'm gonna
load up amplitube 5 which is a bit of
software that simulates guitar amps and
bass amps and I'm going to pick what I
think will work straight away and if it
doesn't we'll go searching for a little
bit more but the remember the only thing
that's going into this is just the
just that top end
[Music]
the difference between that and what
you've got no different bass signals
yeah so we've got the bottom end and the
top it's really clever the problem is
you'll be able to explain technically
why but the problem is with doing any
kind of saturation or distortion on low
end frequencies is you end up pulling
out
the low end and you end up being left
with all of the multiples and the
harmonics
and you're just transferring your energy
from here up to there precisely that's
why I like to split and if I'm even if
I'm going to do a real distorted base
and have it like something Muse would do
or whatever the keeping the clean bottom
end and then sometimes if I can't do
that I will put in a sine wave
underneath that will be
whatever the chord is of doing that just
holding a consistent box
and this is a good example of where top
end frequencies the higher up you go the
less you'd need of the less amplitude
you need of that because the air will
hear it better if we feed in
[Music]
is it just the years that's not the
physics that's that's the physiology
rather than but would it be could there
be enough I guess well I would say could
there be an argument that because low
end frequencies are physically longer
you're not going to have as many there
and at the top end you're gonna have
more yeah to come but yeah I said I
jumped to physiology but it's a
combination obviously it's a question of
just what the length scales are yeah and
how big this is yeah yeah so yeah no
fair
[Music]
but again at this point the levels are
insignificant what I'm doing is is what
I said at the beginning we're separating
things out so I can very quickly go oh
it sounds like it's too much sub and
you've got a place to just turn it out
you're not diving into eqs and screwing
up other things everything's being put
in its place
a lot of people put too much distortion
on guitars Distortion also compresses so
you lose dynamic range although I said
earlier compressors can create dynamic
range you're not going to be creating
too much dynamic range with with a
distortion the key is for me is to layer
up the distortions rather than having
one big Distortion when you get into
supersaturation on any of this software
stuff I find it doesn't model as well as
having a real amp
so it's better to stack
distortions so each one's doing a bit of
the Distortion and then it sounds more
real at the end in terms of software in
terms of the frequency bands or no no in
terms of just just right so if you
wanted a really big distorted pedal
sound rather than putting in one pedal
and whacking the drive up F2 at half
drive oh wow and it sounds to me more
naturally as this is anecdotal data but
if I get a real amp or real pedal and
whack it up and play in the analog
domain sounds great if I get two on here
and kind of turn them halfway up I can
get somewhat closer to me it sounds
better or the more saturated stuff
since two guitars now so we've got now
got two guitars and I'm just panning
them left and right dead left and right
[Music]
I've grouped the guitars to a single
what would be a single fader so that I
can treat them all together the Rhythm
guitars and there's a lot of bottom end
which is happening let's say some sort
of like 50 hertz up to about 110 120
hertz which is where we've got the sub
of the bass drum and the sub of the bass
guitar see in the mix
[Music]
those frequencies you can hear them when
you just listen to guitars on their own
but then when you put the guitars in the
mix and you take those frequencies out
there's
gonna be at some point this marginal
difference you're not really noticing it
and what you end up with is you're going
to be putting a load of load of energy
into those lower frequencies which at
the end of the day is just going to stop
the bass drum kicking it's going to stop
the bass guitar more clean add mud do
you know what an interfering this is
what I was saying earlier is you want
this bit here's the bass drum above that
we've got the sub of the basics are
above that we're going to have a little
bit of low energy and you're kind of
working it out and
um not only have you got the frequency
spectrum there but you've also got the
stereo spectrum because we've got two
speakers not one that it's all coming
out of
so by having two guitars because you
recorded the rhythm guitar twice you're
human so it's not going to be perfect
which is exactly what we want that's not
an insult it's it's it's it's nice that
they're different so then we can pan
them left and right so suddenly the
guitars feel like they're coming in for
this so when we start to put vocals and
other things in they're going to come in
the middle you're gonna have the guitars
there which will have had certain
frequencies pulled out the other thing
is is with bottom end frequencies as you
know 60 symbols Here's the the the low
end frequencies are physically long
and if you have things that are coming
out of right and left that are different
that have those physically long
frequencies depending where you're
standing between the two speakers you're
not you're not going to be always in an
Optimum place right in the middle and
they might come together and you'll get
interference patterns over them you want
them to be as identical as possible in
in the two speakers and then the higher
up the Spectrum you you go where the
frequency narrow you can have more
difference in the data Because by the
time they get into the the cancellation
will be a problem so
um this is another reason because we've
got two guitars in their pan left and
right you don't want loads of bottom
ending those guitars because you might
go like that and go oh there's a load of
horrible bottom end and then put your
head back and so I mean oh I can't hear
any bottom end at all and that's that's
an I mean we have that on a stage with
the band they'll be running low-end
frequencies through monitors and through
stuff and you can literally walk across
the stage and have places where it's
almost totally silent because it's a
perfect sound wave and then when you're
walking in and out of interference and
you can almost measure stepping going oh
this is the start of the wave this is
the stopper and you can find the Peaks
and trough and measure manually the the
wave in the physical length of that
frequency by doing that so everywhere
we're trying to avoid that with having
with having things that are very very
stereo from a technical point of view I
can't I'm not in control of what the end
listener is going to be listening
through okay and you just trying to
limit as many headaches and problems and
sometimes it's like well I'd love to do
this because in my room I can sit in the
middle and have all this bottom end that
sounds stereo and wonderful and you know
you go and play it in the car or on your
mate stereo and it's just gonna sound
awful
[Music]
so that's a very good example of when
you have those guitars by themselves you
don't have that bottom end but when you
have the full mix
they just sit there perfectly so in a in
a in another day if I you know we'll get
a basic mix done today and I might come
back and revisit something so there
might be a bit if the guitar was on its
own yeah I'd put those frequencies back
in and automate having them in and then
cut out at certain points you could do
it with a multi-band compressor you
could effectively have the compressor
pull out all the bottom end when the
other instrument playing and you could
which in a live environment you you'd
have to do it something like that
because you haven't got the the scope to
it that's it there's so many there's so
many ways to do the same thing and
[Music]
this is what the guitar sounds like
[Applause]
[Music]
and really because the the other guitars
you know they've got that that frequency
scoop where where all the mud would be
and then I've done some shaping in the
top end and made it it's almost like
that guitar to stand out needs to be all
the frequencies that you wouldn't want
to hear in a big fat rhythm guitar
you're kind of boosting the nasty
exactly yeah
so the if one guitar is doing that
simplified the other guitar is doing
that what I'm trying to do now is add
another layer of chaos so I've got that
guitar sound
which we've ended up with there and then
I actually want to send it to
to a Leslie
um
which if you don't know what a Leslie
speaker is a Leslie speaker is a speaker
that spins so you're constantly getting
the Doppler effect so the idea is I want
to mix in some of that
and if I just mix that Leslie under
that's perfect it's gonna sound like a
siren this is where it's not science
it's more of an emotional thing so
certainly for that side but I'm saying
from an emotional point of view people
have Associated certain sounds with
certain things so if you give them a
unless it's really speed up and you get
a horrible sound it's it's it's worse
than a normal siren you know it's it's a
little bit more painful which is
[Applause]
what sometimes you want to create an
area of discomfort you want to have a
nice verse or something and then you
create in the middle an area of
discomfort which genuinely sounds
horrible so when you get to the chorus
it's beautiful again Dynamics in music
are having an old trick in songs would
be in the old days you'd have the verse
at that level and then you get the
bridge and turn it up the whole side up
a bit you get the chorus and turn the
whole up a bit and then come back to the
bridge and you're maybe adding your DB
or a DB and a half for each section and
when you put it through the final Master
limiter it will all kind of then squash
back down to the same but obviously the
verses are less compressed than the
chorus at that point and you you end up
with this perception of dynamic change
which um yeah you know which people find
exciting
so again I'll try and take out some 500
what a surprise
it probably doesn't need a huge amount
more might just add a little bit of
Reverb some sort of yeah
less of a normal Reverb more of a kind
of a a delayed Reverb I think
you know I just want one repeat on each
side
that almost sounds floydy doesn't it it
does
since do tend to this is where I
wouldn't go for a delay this is where
we'll get uh quite a washy Reverb on it
and I think in the nature of synth
sometimes the cheaper the Reverb the
more cool it sounds and also how much
stereo is in in this I mean how stereo
is this sound
my point is it could be more stereo yeah
so I'm gonna do a trick on um you know a
delay is so delay would be you'd have
something where it plays a signal ah
so it's giving you kind of delays on it
and if you do it to 100 mix you get uh
so you wouldn't hear the initial thing
so if I put a stereo delay on so I can
have a different delay on each side one
day like I can have completely off on
the right hand side I can have it
completely on and I can just delay it by
say 20 milliseconds so we're going to
shift
the right hand side of the signal by 20
milliseconds which will make it much
wider and then put a Reverb on top of
that and it will just be it can be there
and all around and like a big warm
blanket around you without ever needing
to be so loud in the mix that it's
interfering that's the big one that's
the plan yeah
maybe even more
you wouldn't want to type guitar to be
30 minutes you'd hear that but that's
starting to sound
[Music]
this is taken directly from a simulation
of how a wave function evolves in or how
the probability density
evolves in something called the particle
in a Box model which is something that
undergraduate physicists all do they
love it so very very much they see it in
first year they see it in second year
and third year and fourth year see it so
many times over and we covered this in a
computer file video Sean and myself I
don't know a couple of years ago
um on superposition and this is the
output from the simulation we describe
in that video and what you're hearing is
quantum Dynamics simulation of quantum
Dynamics from a musical point of view
what I'm hearing there is there's some
kind of noise which has some sort of
Center frequency around it which is
going down very very slowly and then
within that you're boosting up and down
the harmonics with some kind of back and
forward if I was doing that I'd
basically have two phases one really
long and one really short and they'd be
working with each other is that what
it's doing oh my God that's precisely
what's going on we have the in terms of
the superposition we have two key
components here one is we're oscillating
much more quickly than the other they're
moving in and out of fears and that's
sweeping your hearing is exactly as you
described
you say it's imagine I've actually got a
76 model 1176 model because she got the
attack and release and I got really fast
attack and release so that I'm getting
all those
nasty transients that are coming out
with a vocal Year all those are gonna
jump out so I'm squishing them down
there I'm using a 2A as a second
compressor over the lot which has got a
much slower kind of nice attack
[Music]
so in between the two compressors I'm
going to put a tiny bit of um
if I do an H delay usually
I want to get it really quite tight so
I'm going to get it a 16th of a bar ping
pong and just to sort of thicken it just
to thicken it yeah so it's kind of got
it Bit by Bit by Bit by bits
hello can we go then you get that which
is happening Left Right which gives it
that more with a kind of a width and
something but the width is not getting
the vocals are there but the effect is
there
and this will be very strange I'm going
to take this down
an octave so oh okay
I think you won't really hear the note
of it in the music it will just it's a
bit like what you did with the bass in
terms of having the split and the sub
instead of doing that we're actually
going to pitch it down
[Music]
today
[Applause]
The Roots the Roots
we just got to the bit which we recorded
in the lecture theater with the students
and Dave has got the wonderful challenge
of embedding this and mashing this with
the rest of the song so leave it up to
Dave's Studio Wizardry to well embed
this that would be good because I
recorded the audio and it's not very
good no no no so um I'm not going to
make any complaints about the assistant
engineer on the phone but we're using
the clarity VX plugin by waves to
isolate the voice and try and bring the
voice out a little bit more which is a
neural network based uh plugin
systems
so I'm going to do some eq'ing on this
because there's an is that a lot of that
kind of noise and we really want to get
the top end out make it clear and then
I'm probably going to do the same as I
did with the synth I'm going to have a
right and a left version so that so that
the right is pushed a little bit and
then that way we're getting the charm
from the left and the right rather than
having it on to make your life even more
difficult as a spoken word bet over the
top actually that doesn't make my life
do I think the fact that we have that
coming left and right will give the
space for the middle because again it's
it's about space three-dimension left
right frequency all of it it's um yeah
trying to make things not conflict
foreign
[Music]
we see that such a drastic departure
from ordinary ideas as the Assumption of
superposition relationships
right so now I need a compressor on that
just to really smooth it out in general
the result will not be determined
you know what it's about it's also
bloody weird and esoteric we can't
understand any of the fundamentals so
let's just shut up and calculate
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
sit by stairs
don't lie
up and down
again
[Music]
to push in the direction
thank you
[Music]
conserve the norm
didn't have any
how many
are we reborn reborn
[Music]
[Applause]
sway we say that such a drastic
departure from
only on account
recognition of the
reservation
in a given state General the resort will
not be
[Music]
we will keep away
your face
[Music]
a magnet is about the same height as I
am will be filled with liquid helium but
90 liters of hit liquid helium in there
the
uhv the ultra high vacuum Chambers have
been added on top and you slice that
open to expose the surface now the atoms
that are at that surface are much less
happy than they were when they're in the
bulk